[Musique]
il faut absolument que l'on soit
autorisé à réouvrir les parcs et jardins
pas pour y faire des pique-niques pas
pour stationner faire des attroupements
mais pour que les parisiens puissent
quand même marché
on voit bien combien de notre ville et
danse combien on est nombreux les
parisiens se sont bien comportées
pendant son recrutement
et la voilà il tant qu'ils inspirent
à sortir beaucoup de gens qui sont dans
des petits appartements
donc ça ne les excuse pas de ne pas
faire attention mais en tous les cas à
nous aussi d'organiser la ville et là
j'ai besoin quand même que le
gouvernement n'a ni nom nous n'ouvrirons
pas les parcs et jardins à paris en ile
de france ainsi que dans les autres
régions qui sont classées rouge parce
que non pas qu'on n'a pas envie que les
gens puissent sortir prendre l'air mais
que ça peut être extrêmement tentant par
le soleil que nous avons aujourd'hui que
les gens se regroupent trop ça mastro
qui ne respectent pas les groupes de dix
et qui ne reste plus pas respecté les
conditions des gestes barrières